Oh
[Music]
all right welcome to GD 50 this is
lecture 10 today we'll be talking about
portal so portal is a very iconic game I
think most of us have probably seen it
before the gist is you have a portal gun
a gun that shoots just these elliptical
portals if you look through one you can
effectively see what's sort of coming
out the other one which is pretty cool
and vice versa and then if you walk in
between the portals you'll actually be
teleported to the other side and so they
achieve a lot of really interesting
effects with some pretty cool tricks and
stuff and actually Valve themselves will
be coming to give a talk on a lot of the
technology that they used on the second
so we can get a glimpse into their
version of portal my version of portal
is a bit simpler but we'll look at a lot
of the same sort of principles and see
how I accomplished a lot of the same
things so this is also the last lecture
of the semester and we've covered a lot
of ground I have a few screenshots here
to show some of the games that we've
talked about you know the very first
game was pong and we've come sort of a
long way we've gone through very simple
sort of rkd Atari Lite games like this
and you know I've gone and created
worlds effectively and you know now
we're in 3d we're doing all kinds of
awesome stuff but these this was where
we started the course and it's kind of
fun to look back and see where we've
come so you know here we talked about
scoring and just effectively drawing
shapes onto the screen then we
transitioned to flappy bird or 50 bird
and you know we had sprites and
characters and we talked about scrolling
and infinite level procedural generation
type algorithms and that was fun we took
things a step higher than that with
breakout where we had the same sort of
procedural ideas in the context of a
very famous arcade game and we talked
about particle systems and some arcade
style physics and high scores then we
went into puzzle games we talked about
match three and how to actually
calculate what goes on to determine
whether we've gotten a match and how to
clear blocks and how to tween things do
operations over time so this
asynchronicity
then we went into probably what is my
favorite lecture which was Super Mario
Brothers and we talked about how to
create procedural worlds that all look
very different with some very simple
algorithms and then we had triggers and
you
sort of happening then Legend of Zelda
came and we had this infinite dungeon
algorithm and we had enemies walking
around that we could use a sword on so
it felt more like an actual action game
action RPG then we took a look a brief
look at physics in the context of box 2d
and with Angry Birds and I still
remember the like ballpit example was
probably my favorite part of that and
then probably the most complicated
example of the semester was Pokemon
where we actually had a full semi full
turn-based battle system and random
encounters and like a little world where
there was actually two main stages to
our world where there was the field and
the battle scene which is a very common
thing to have in RPGs following Pokemon
which was the most complicated codebase
we went into unity which was our first
foray into 3d and even though we were
just exploring 2.5 D we still got a
chance to look at you know how does the
Unity engine work and how do we get
actual 3d models onto the screen and we
put together a very simple flappy bird
SK game so that we could sort of recycle
prior ideas last week we looked at Dredd
50 which was sort of a dread halls
horror inspired game where we got to
look at lighting and how to actually
transition between scenes and use some
basic UI in unity and today we'll be
talking about how to use how to create a
game similar to this although much
simpler today is mostly just a tech demo
more than anything else but this is a
screenshot of the actual game portal and
as you can see they do a lot of really
cool fancy things they have a portal on
sort of a slope they have another portal
coming out of the front wall or back
they're different colors so you can
differentiate between left and right
orange and blue they have sort of this
object here on the side and I believe
that's to shoot cubes out which this
here is a cube which you can then grab
with your gun and then shoot it through
portals and see it come in and out of
portals which is pretty cool and we'll
talk today about how to create sort of a
simple version of this and primarily
just the aspect of how do I create a
portal that looks out of another scene
and see it updating in real time and how
do i teleport and get back back and
forth between the portals and carry a
weapon and then shoot array that'll
actually place a portal where I want to
in the game world
so today some of the topics we'll talk
about so one holding a weapon so we've
had it we've used the first-person
controller and this is a very easy and
simple thing to do
but it helps illustrate what parenting
is and so we'll talk about that
raycasting is the actual shooting out of
ray from your object Z Direction forward
so you have an X and a Y which are sort
of the angle at which you're moving
around but then you have Z which is
always if you're using vector if using
the forward vector from your character
it's going to be forward from the in the
z axis wherever you're looking
effectively and so that allows us to we
can cast array in that in that sense
which just means you know shoot a
straight line an invisible straight line
from that point and wherever that point
intersects with an object we can get
some information about that and then do
whatever work we need to do in this case
take a portal prefab and just like a fix
it to the wall basically rotate it from
its default position and then just like
put it flat up against a wall texture
mask masking is sort of how we're going
to achieve this portal effect right
because when we when we create what's
called a render texture in unity which
here's the third bullet our render
texture just means a texture that we are
rendering to with a camera so rather
than have a texture be an asset in your
game in your hierarchy with something
that you've made in Photoshop you can
actually dynamically create it at
runtime with a camera's what the camera
is seeing and unity gives us to you for
free very easily with what's called a
render texture which is just another
asset type and then texture map masking
is effectively sort of kind of the same
thing as stenciling where we can choose
certain pixels of an object to delete in
this case we create a texture that's
white in the center and then black
around the edges in a sort of elliptical
shape and what that allows us to do is
tell it with a simple shader don't
render these pixels when you actually
render the render texture just render
the ones in the middle and so that's how
we achieve an ellipse just by
effectively discarding the pixels in the
outer rim decals are is an idea in 3d
games where ad college is something that
you have fixed a texture or some object
that you've fixed to a surface in this
case we'll be using decals to act as our
portal so our portals are actually just
gonna be decals they're just meshes with
a render texture affixed to them and
then all we need to do is just slap them
onto a wall whenever we shoot it and we
get array that intersects with the wall
and that'll have the effect of actually
making it look like we're putting a
portal on a wall when in reality we're
just taking a mesh
kinda like slapping it onto a wall some
other examples of decals that you've
probably seen in other games are for
example bullet holes which use the same
principle teleporting is very easy
although the FPS controller sort of
complicates things a little bit so we'll
talk about how when about sort of
solving it sort of solving the problem
of teleporting in a way that makes sense
it's usually just as simple as a change
on the you know setting something's
transforms position to another
transforms position setting the rotation
to the transforms rotation but the FPS
controller caches its rotation data so
in order to that teleport cleanly you
sort of have to override some default
behavior and lastly we'll take a look at
some new tools that unity is introduced
with twenty eighteen point one pro
builder and pro grids which allow you to
actually model geometry in the scene and
this is what the assignment is going to
be focused on because going forward it's
probably I foresee it being a major part
of sort of modern unity development
and/or prototyping the ability to model
your scene in unity without needing a
third party program heavily optimizes
the actual creation process and allows
you to do easy what's called gray boxing
meaning create a level for like you know
to create a level in your game engine
and then prototype it test it make sure
that it's actually game playable right
off the bat that's called great boxing
but first let's get a demo so is anybody
want to come up here and play my
implementation of portal yesterday James
is landlocked all right James you're not
landlocked let's go all right so I'm
gonna go ahead and set that up and so
disclaimer there's actually a bug in
this as well so I'm curious to see if
you can spot what the bug is go ahead
and hit play as soon as you're ready and
then the mouse on the right will be your
sort of angle of your portal so we see
here I have a character with a portal
gun created so if James if you shoot a
wall with the left Mouse that will
create a portal and then they've used
the right Mouse so that's one other bug
this so let's go ahead and restart the
program actually
so that's one bug and so if we avoid
stepping into a portal that's there and
this this could be fixed in a couple of
ways so now you have a so okay so now
you have two portals basically created
do you see what's wrong with the the
portal as it is here on both of these
portals actually oh actually no I'm
sorry these portals are actually
completely right but walk through them
and I will show you okay so you can see
it works it works pretty well right
you're you you can not only see your
character rendering completely are
moving in real time when the other
texture but you can walk you can jump
through them or walk through them you
can jump with spacebar if you want and
that will teleport you out the other end
so you see from the perspective of the
other portal but if we try shooting one
of the other walls for instance like the
one of these white walls you can see
something weird happens with this
particular wall anything to strike you
as odd about that portal anybody it's
upside down and so if you walk through
it though it works perfectly fine now
the reason that it's upside down I spent
probably like 10 15 hours trying to
debug why this is it's in a state of
what's called gimbal lock so this prefab
right here there's three axes of
rotation in 3d space and if you perform
a rotation in some odd way there are
these things called Euler angles which
are your angles of rotation about the x
y&z axis and you can sort of think of it
think of them as sort of being able to
rotate and interdependently but there is
a situation in which you can for some
reason unities internal representation
of a rotation can get messed up by
manipulating these angles and so you can
actually lock two axes together such
that rotating like for example in this
case it's Z and Y they both rotate each
other and so you're unable to get in
this particular case the portal to
rotate about the axis that lets it like
look like it's right side up based on
the walls surface normal and so how do I
maybe another week it probably could
have debugged it but I had to
unfortunately ran out of time but if you
don't the interesting thing is if you do
shoot that same wall so try and shoot
that wall the other wall with like put
both put one portal on the on the buggy
wall so there the right wall it's only
that wall by the way for some reason so
that wall is a bit so notice that now
it's right-side up
so if you shoot both portals on the same
wall that buggy wall they do get
right-side up and I for the life of me
couldn't ascertain exactly as to why I
know it's a gimbal lock unfortunately I
was unable to debug it quite in time but
every other wall including the ceiling
on the floor will work if you shoot a
portal up on them so you can create one
up there and then you can jump through
it see how it's looking down and it'll
sort of put you at the top and
altogether - the weird single wall that
gimbal locks the portal we have a pretty
functional implementation of a very
basic portal game right we have a this
model here is parented to the camera so
it's always gonna look in the exact same
direction as the camera we shoot array
from the tip of the gun and then
whenever that ray intersects with a
plane in this case any of these walls we
get the information about the
intersection and we flip the decal the
portal decal such that it's the same
angle as the wall rotation and then what
what happens when we actually collide
with one of the portals just in code if
we were to think about how to implement
like the behavior that goes on here
it's transporting the player and it's
doing effectively setting the players
transform.position
to the same transform position as the
portal now if we do the same thing on
the rotation the player ends up getting
AB it's the FPS controllers rotation
gets a bit skewed if you mess with its X
and z rotation the default controller so
all we do for now is we just we keep
those values the X&Y rotation but we
just changed the Y rotation Y rotation
is is position in space like this
effectively so that allows us to get
when we jump out of the wall we noticed
that he's you know sort of like flat
from it but if we jump through any of
the wall portals so if you like create a
portal on the wall here and then jump
through it you'll notice that you sort
of get a you know you're sort of angry
at the right and the reason that it's
skewed is because this one's upside down
and so it flips though it's flipping the
camera though that's rendering the
texture and it's looking a little bit
weird but when you jump through it
basically keeps your X and Z but rotates
your Y position such that you come out
looking as if you went straight through
the portal rather than by default it has
you look like look back at the portal
that you came out of which is a bit
weird or whatever direction you were
walking through it when you went through
the portal
that's just default this is rendering a
it's a render texture so there's a
camera actually behind each of these
portals so the prefab is a mesh with a
render texture and then behind it
there's a camera and so the camera is
rendering in real-time what's in front
of the portal basically from behind it
and so it's seeing your model from both
of these portals both cameras are seeing
your model and so it shows up in the
render texture on the other on the other
on the other portal so it's effectively
like looking at two video cameras
instead of a portal it's a sort of a
trick and this is a very crude
implementation of portal the actual game
uses a much more sophisticated algorithm
for and it also tracks your position
with the camera so that like based on
your angle of rotation you'll actually
see something different on the on the
texture there but it's a lot more
complicated to put some like that
together I have some resources that have
included in the lecture in the
assignment that'll show you actually how
to do that but it would take many many
more hours than I had to put this demo
together
yeah it's fixed so if you actually look
at it from the side you'll notice that
it's like just a flat texture
there's no perspective ultimately its
perspective and there's an awesome video
that I'm going to show later in the
slides by a youtuber named Brock YZ
where I actually implements a
perspective correct shader that allows
you to see and with with camera tracking
of the player like both cameras will
track the position of the player as well
as render a texture and the result of
that is because the cameras are changing
their position it's sort of like
changing the angle at which the scene is
being rendered on to the portal mesh
but also the way that's being drawn is a
little bit different and so he has a
really cool shader that does that and
then valve when they present they'll
actually show how they went about doing
it which is even more complex but it
looks really good and is a lot more you
know technically interesting but yeah
that's my sort of implementation
bare-bones implementation of what makes
a portal work so and it's somewhat it's
somewhat fun to like walk through these
you know walk through these portals and
just sort of play around with it now the
reason that if you just walk into a blue
portal it doesn't work is because the
portals are actually stored off-screen
until you use them and so a way in which
so I'll open up the scene here oh by the
way thanks James for coming up to demo I
appreciate it
so the portals are over here right both
of them are right here and so what'll
out what that does is when you only
shoot one of them the other one is still
out here so when you walk through it you
end up just teleporting outside of the
level and in order to not have that
happen what you really need to do is
have a flag on both of them that just
says don't teleport unless they've been
shot once right and that'll prevent
that'll prevent that sort of behavior
from happening simple fix but an
entertaining one to take a look at and
that is my crude implementation of
portal it's far from being anywhere near
as polished as the actual game and there
is the slight weird wall that gimbal
locks the portal which I would like to
figure out why exactly that is but
everything else is sort of in here now
it doesn't include something like
shooting blocks through it but the same
sort of principles would apply because
all we're effectively doing on the
portal is saying it's it's basically a
trigger right it's got a box Collider on
it and it says if I collide with
something and in this case the player I
want to teleport that Collider to the
other portal which means that the portal
sort of have to link to each other right
one portal has to have a reference to
the other portal so that it can say
teleport to the linked portal and
vice-versa so the linked portal should
have a reference to the other portals I
can say teleport back if you collide
with this and so if we have another
object like say we shoot a cube into the
portal it would also get teleported to
the
other portal right and now the other
consideration for that is like if it's a
rigid body and it has physics applied to
it for example let's say it's it's going
like 10 on the X and it teleports to a
portal that's like perpendicular to it
and it's still going 10 to the X then as
soon as it shoots out of the portal it's
gonna go straight left which isn't the
behavior we want we want it to go
forward so it's like linear velocity
needs to be calibrated to go in a
different direction didn't have enough
time to put a full demo of that together
but if you were curious in a nutshell
that's sort of like what you would need
to do in order to implement like some
basic physics with portal so holding a
weapon based on the screen shot can
anybody tell me how they think I got I
went from just a plain FPS controller to
an FPS controller holding a gun yeah
there's not really a notion necessarily
of pixels in 3d space because that
changes depending on your resolution but
yes unity units so it's effectively
equivalent to a meter and you can change
what it represents in unity settings but
yeah I mean it's not it isn't
necessarily have to be one unit it can
be an arbitrary amount and what it
really was was me going into here with
this model by the way got this model on
the asset store for free so the asset
store is an awesome place if you're
looking to just quickly prototype your
game they didn't have any like obvious
portal guns portal gun look-alikes that
looked really good so I just like all
this guns got like the same kind of
color I'll just choose this like a
sci-fi kind of gun but as you can see
there's a hierarchy here now how are we
keeping the gun like a fixed to where
the camera is looking do we know
yeah the camera followed the gun do we
know do you have any guesses as to how
we're doing that it's actually a really
really simple thing so all we're doing
Oh Stephen yeah kind of so said that the
guns transform to the cameras transform
but just with an offset and that is
effectively what we're doing and in
order to accomplish that it's really as
simple as just making it a child of that
thing so this is the first person
character controller it's got a camera
attached to it anything that you parent
to something or you make a child of
something else it's going to have the
same transform like changes applied to
it including rotation so by making the
gun just a child of the first person
character which is where the camera is
here first person character by the way
is just a subcomponent of the FPS
controller which every name - portal gun
FPS controller here the portal gun
anytime this first person character is
rotated which is the camera so any time
the camera is rotated it applies that
rotation to the portal gun gun here this
gun mesh and so that gives you the
effect so what you do is you start it
off by you know you figure out okay
where's the you start off in 3d space
like this you're looking at your game
scene and you have your character and
then you move your gun object around in
this case I could go let's go to layouts
2x3 so we can see in real time see you
this is the game view this is what's
gonna look like on startup I'm gonna go
over to my game my editor view here and
I'm just going to grab the actual gun
component here the gun object I should
say going to position it and I can just
move it right and so this is how you can
like change where your gun is relative
to the camera
and this is going to affect sort of how
it feels right like I could put it here
and it's kind of a little lower I could
put it here it feels a little weird
obviously because it doesn't have a hand
on it so it's kind of almost looks like
a VR game and that's kind of like what
VR games do is they take your hand
positions and then they like the gun
transform is locked to the basically
where your hand controllers are in this
case all I did was I just positioned it
I said I like how it looks right here so
I'm just going to do that and as soon as
I make it a child of the first person
character which is the camera it's just
gonna get all the rotations applied to
it so anytime we make any rotations to
the camera which I'm doing here it stays
exactly aligned with the with the camera
this applies to any operation that you
do in unity when you make any sort of
transform position scale changes they
all get propagated down the chain all
the objects that are children of an
object they get transform operations
applied to them will have the same
transform operations applied to them
sort of like this recursive kind of
effect yeah correct so if you have if
you just import the vanilla FPS
controller and then just make the gun
specifically the gun needs to be a child
of this the first person character of it
because that has the camera and recall
the camera as what's driving our
rotation right because we're moving the
cameras rotation with our mouse that is
ultimately going to determine how the
transform gets applied to the gun but
yes
and so just whenever you're doing
anything in unity and you'll do a lot of
things where like one things movement or
scale or rotation should apply to
another thing just remember that's
usually just as easy as making it a
child of something else so any other
questions as to how we've gone about
implementing the weapon all right so ray
casting so ray casting is a nice feature
that unity gives you for free it's part
of the physics sort of namespace in
unity part of the scripting API and what
it allows you to do is effectively look
at from whatever transform you're
operating at or whatever Opera transform
you give it as a the source so whatever
point you give it as the source
you can tell a direction give it a
vector as a direction and in this case
what we're doing is we're saying
transform dot forward and transform dot
forward just means basically wherever
we're looking x and y and then straight
in the z direction so if you're doing it
on a camera it's always gonna be exactly
what you're looking at it's always going
to be exactly forward on the like
transform dot forward on a camera is
always gonna be like center of the
screen wherever you're looking at and so
if we cast array from the point of our
character or actually we're doing it
from the point of our gun to the
transform dot forward like a line going
from our player to transform it's a the
forward vector of its character the
forward vector of our camera it's going
to have the effect of we can shoot
something right we can we can create a
ray cast and they're just like a fixed
something wherever that ray intersects
and it'll be the exact center of our
camera view does that make sense to
shoot a line from the zero your z axis
which is your forward vector and then
based on how you've rotated the camera x
and y are the x and y part of that and
Z's always forward that'll let you shoot
things or cast rays directly in front of
you and you can cast rays between any
object and from any source point with
any sort of direction you want but it's
particularly pertinent in the context of
how we've shot it from our gun and so
here's a screen shot actually what that
looks like and so the nice thing about
unity actually is it has a function
called debug ray or debug draw ray which
I'll show you here I implemented it in a
function called the a component rather
called debug ray so that you can
actually see where array is being cast
in your scene and eliminate any
ambiguity there so you can see draw ray
transform top position and then we just
say transform dot transform Direction
vector 3 dot forward and then times a
thousand just means a thousand units you
know from that point and then color dot
red and so what that'll do is only in
the only in the editor view so this
doesn't apply in the in the actual game
this is just a debug call debug draw
Raye and so it'll render in the this
scene up here just not down here so if
we hit play I actually have all the
portals rendering a debug ray from their
forward transform and for my gun so you
can see it there
I'm just doing a debug draw ray with
just transform dot forward and using my
transform drop position as the source
point and forward is always going to be
notice that the the Z arrow it's always
always following the same direction
right x and y are sort of changing you
know the back planes are like how that's
rotated but Z is always forward right
and so that's the that's the ray coming
from our gun and if we shoot a portal
there and there
I have those also set to or my positive
so I can rotate the view a little bit I
have those also set to draw a ray from
their forward position so those are also
drawing array from what's their vector
three dot or their transform dot forward
their directional vector but yeah ray
casting it's pretty it's pretty easy
just to get some pretty simple collision
test this way with guns with a lot of
different things but primarily you'll
see this used for like calculating
whether something is blocking something
else like if a car is moving and it's
text maybe if it detects another car
like ever and grand theft auto for
example and your cars driving down the
center of the road or something and it
wants to know whether there's a car two
units in front of it or something
it is cast array and see if there's any
geometry there from its forward vector
right transformed opposition card
opposition and then get its forward
vector which will be its z direction and
then it depends on whether maybe you're
games top down maybe it's not your
forward vector maybe it's your Y vector
in that case but that'll effectively
give you not only that you've got a
collision but also tell you where the
collision is too which is nice and we do
that in the portal gun script
where we call physics out raycast so
this this is the function by the way to
actually do the raycast the interesting
thing about ray casting and unity is
that it returns a struct object and so
you need to declare this hit object
which will tell you all the information
about the hit so like where it was
whether there was a hit to begin with
and what there like the normal was on
the surface that it collided with so the
angle at which that sort of plane was
projecting out and then you call physics
dot ray cast with a position and a
transform direction and then you pass an
out hit so out is interesting because
out is sort of C sharps way of allowing
you to return multiple values to
something so out is gonna be an object a
in this case is gonna be our ray cast
hit that way declared up here right
which is a struct which recall is just a
collection of variables like an C or C++
and out hit just means that normally we
pass in these values to the function
they don't get manipulated right but we
pass in this variable as out which will
allow this function to actually change
the data inside this this hit variable
and so the result of that is hit from
this point forward contains all the
information about the raycast
that we that we that we just triggered
and when we call math F dot infinity
that just means raycast
to infinity but just until you know
forever and ever and unity obviously
doesn't check infinitely whether
something's collided with something it
optimizes the right way but you can use
that just if you don't want to
necessarily specify I want to check two
units or five units or a thousand units
in front of me I want to just check
forever and see if it collides with
something in your scene right and then
as you can see here once that once we
have detected a collision we play a
portal sound we get the right portal and
then we set the portals transform and
rotation based upon the hits point and
rotation and that's pretty much all
that's involved in shooting the gun and
you can take a look through here if you
want to get a sense of how it works and
maybe explore also the raycast the
physics dot ray cast
section of the API just to understand
what exactly it returns and what you can
do with it but in this case this is how
we're using it to detect whether we've
intersected with the wall so it'll will
intersect with any sort of mesh and then
when it does it'll tell you exactly how
it did so that is what ray casting is
ray casting has another name for like
old-school games like Wolfenstein the
method of rendering was called ray
casting where you generate one sort of
you would generate a ray from every
pixel of the screen effectively although
it was mostly just every line of the
screen and you would just look up and
down for every where intersected in the
scene and then just create draw like a
texture there and so that would generate
a world that was that looked 3d but you
couldn't move up and down because it was
always generating all arrays completely
forward and so you were locked onto two
axes but Ray casting is different in
unity ray casting is just literally
casting a ray in 3d space versus the
sort of 2d space that it was casting in
games like Wolfenstein there's another
screenshot of normals from our portals
casting out Ray's and I want to look up
and see if I can just find a picture of
what Wolfenstein looked like I'm pretty
sure most folks are probably familiar
with not the new one yea Wolfenstein 3d
so this was this is Wolfenstein so
old-school but this sort of ray casting
was differently it would go over it
would basically shoot rays from every
single line of the screen up and down
and it would detect based on the level
geometry which was very simple level
geometry it was just basically whether
there was a wall there or not true or
false kind of like a 2d image and it
would draw based on how far away it was
that particular point of the geometry it
would just draw like pixels from a
texture a specific texture at a specific
point and they had to interpolate where
on the texture it was was a little more
complicated but in case you see Wolfen
star in case you see ray casting used in
those two different senses in the case
of old-school game engines in the case
of modern unity sort of raycasting that
is what is involved in that so any
questions as to how sort of in a
nutshell the raycasting works in the
context of our game here so
unfortunately no the oculus does not
work on Mac they do not have Mac support
and so we were unable to get a sort of
version of it working we don't have the
means to necessarily transport given how
much time we had now getting VR working
in unity is actually very easy if I
recall correctly I have to just remember
the exact menu I had sort of anticipated
talking about this before
I think it's player XR settings yeah
that's how it that's what it is so in
order to get so it's incredibly easy if
you want to do a game in VR in unity and
you have a PC out of the box it's very
easy just to get it working all you need
to go do is go to edit project settings
and then go to player and then in the XR
setting so unity has like deemed all of
its VR AR stuff as XR ne click virtual
reality supported here and you have your
oculus rift or vive or whatever plugged
in it'll just work with the camera like
right off the bat right out the gate so
it's pretty easy you may have to solve
drivers on your computer such that your
computer knows that you have an oculus
plugged in but assuming that's all set
up your project will is as easy as just
clicking this checkbox hololens the
oculus rift and I'm pretty sure the vibe
like 90% should the vive I'm not a
hundred percent we can we can google it
though let's see unity
it looks like it does it looks like it
definitely does yeah and of course if he
already Windows PC is very I apologize I
thought I totally thought going into the
course that unity were era that oculus
worked on a Mac but as of even October
they were like it's not gonna work on
any MacBook ever released so only on a
PC unfortunately that said if you do
have a PC super easy to get working and
it looks like this is actually pretty
cool tutorial I haven't looked at this
but I tend to like Ray I don't know if
his name is vendor leash or Wonderlic
but he makes really good - game
programming tutorials in general so just
you know because we're coincidentally
here if you guys are curious I really
like this website for basic tutorial
stuff we have five and five as far as I
well five the thing about vibe is you
need to install like walt like ceiling
mounted cameras in order for it to work
so that's kind of out of the equation we
have the the gear vr but you would need
that we would need to export it to
mobile and test it and I just didn't
have I didn't anticipate it not working
for Mac and so it kind of came up a bit
late and so it's on me I apologize but
if you are doing a PC game innocuous and
you want some assistance I'm happy to
like help out it looks like it's very
easy just to get working with the
default FPS controller camera so
definitely reach out if you're
developing oculus and need some
assistance maybe for the next iteration
of our next unity course we can have a a
big sort of VR day or we bring in all
the guns but yeah back to sort of Ray
casting and what we were just talking
about shooting array on your z-axis
based on your rotation get information
from it and then sort of what we do is
we flip the portal based on the hit dot
rotation of the surface that we collided
with and that's effectively all the
raycast I know we need to worry about
for portal but the actual making a
portal is probably the most interesting
part of this whole project and so
let's go ahead and go back into present
mode so a render texture is the means is
a very is a basic it's not a basic means
it is the the fundamental way at which
we go about doing it and there are
various ways to accomplish doing it some
that are more technically challenging
and look a lot nicer than others I did a
sort of simple version of it just to get
a sort of proof of concept out of the
gate but unity makes it really easy just
to get a simple render texture up and
running so a render texture is recall
just a texture in unity so it's an asset
isn't unity asset that you can create
the difference between a render texture
and a texture that you might have
imported from like Photoshop or [ __ ] is
that a render texture can be rendered
too and typically this is used for
things like cameras being rendered to it
although from what I understand you can
render anything to it so you can create
procedural textures this way as well but
in this example here we're creating a
we're essentially creating a screen into
which we're looking at the viewpoint of
our other portal right from from its
forward direction so we can see what it
will look like once we walk out of the
portal and go into the next area and so
a render texture so I have some in the
slides if you want to download the
slides there here you can see exactly
how to create a render texture so
literally just create and then render
texture that creates aa render texture
these are the settings that I used for
the actual render texture so what will
happen
do we think if we use like a low res
render texture just logically let's say
what if my render texture was like 200
pixels by 200 pixels and our resolution
of our game is like 1080p it won't be
blown up because what we're doing is
we're taking a mesh and we're fixing the
texture to it so it'll just scale to
fill the mesh but what will it look like
when it's rendered because it's
rendering at 200 pixel texture it'll
look pixelated it'll look really like
nasty and so in order to fix that
problem typically what you'll do a smart
way to do it would be to dynamically
figure out at runtime what's what's the
resolution of your game right if it's
gonna be rendered in various resolutions
up to 4k maybe down to 720p and then
create a render texture that is the size
of your game and then by doing that
it'll ensure that no matter what your
resolution is it'll always be one to one
pixel ratio even if you're right up
close to it right it'll fill up your
whole screen in this case we went for a
simpler method so we didn't have to do
any dynamic instantiation of the render
texture which you can absolutely do and
is it is the more robust way to do it
but in this case I just chose 1024 by
1024 figuring that that was gonna be
good enough for demonstration purposes
and most of these other settings I
believe actually all these other
settings are completely default render
texture settings the only ones that
changed where this is 256 by 256 by
default and it just looks really
pixelated and nasty especially when
you're right up close to it and then all
we need to do so
once we've created a render texture
right in our in our scene in our assets
so here I'm gonna go to textures this is
where I'm storing all my textures
whether the render textures are not I
have these to render textures here and
so these are by default they're not
going to be mapped to anything because
they're just there's empty render
textures but effectively allocated them
and said something will be rendering to
these later but for now they're just
empty there's placeholders right there
like blank screens but they had TV
hasn't been turned on yet in order to
actually render to them we go into our
firstpersoncharacter sorry not our
firstpersoncharacter we go into whatever
camera we want to render it to render to
the render texture because we're
effectively taking these render textures
and we're rendering a camera view onto
them right
each of the portals has a camera behind
it looking out from it and so we want to
take that cameras of you and we want to
render that on to the other portals face
the other portals render texture the
texture that we're gonna put on to it
and so all we need to do is say here's
my orange portal I have my camera here
every camera has a target texture just
right out the gate so you can just say
okay I'm gonna take my orange portal
texture my render texture that have
instantiated so it knows that it's gonna
be able to receive an input source and
I'm going to just click and drag it
there and it's that simple now whenever
you run the game you'll notice that your
render texture updates I'm not sure if
it updates in real time in the inspector
but it renders if you're if you're
showing it on to a yeah it doesn't
render in the inspector but it will
update if you've affixed it to any other
surface and so what we're doing is we're
fixing it to the meshes that are
associated with each portal
James did you have a question oh sure
the the render texture so I just
right-click and then I go to create and
then a render texture right here and
that will give you most of the settings
that you need to get up and running with
it and you can assign it to a camera but
the important thing is do consider your
resolution for render texture make sure
that's high enough such that your game
won't look pixelated when you're looking
at it like pretty close up yep yep and
so that'll do is create a link between
the two such that anything the camera
sees it's no longer going to be
rendering to the scene or anything like
that just going to render to the texture
and actually I think you can render to
the scene and the texture but these
aren't rendering to the scene at all
they're the only one rendering to the
scene is the first person character
because it's the default camera main
camera
if it's a high too high of a resolution
it's just going to like compress to fit
the the mesh whatever it's affixed to
and you'll probably run into performance
problems but it's not going to break
yeah because you're not fixing it to any
because your resolution is doesn't
really have an effect necessarily on
whatever's in your game world and like
that doesn't cause any issues it gets it
gets interpolated like unity will just
like calculate how to render it to the
screen right yeah like game textures
generally are very high resolution like
four thousand by two thick 4k textures
are often used even if you're running
your game in 1080p in a game engine will
probably optimize it and like downsample
the texture so that is like actually a
1080p texture and you don't like you're
not trying to calculate more draw more
than you need to but unity will figure
that out for you you don't have to worry
about that
but yeah that's that's what a render
texture is and that's that's how we are
creating this illusion remember
everything in the game is an illusion in
this case we're not actually and it is
it's obvious in this example because
we're not actually because the the
textures are flat and there's no
perspective correction you can see that
it's a texture even if it is slightly
convincing from far away like from far
away it actually kind of looks I mean I
don't know if it necessarily looks real
I mean it kind of does right like you
from here it's hard to tell and from
here it kind of looks like we're going
into another room right I go like that
that's the broken wall but go like that
right there's a portal there and it kind
of looks like it's a real room that
we're walking into it's just a
resolution but all we're doing is we're
just drawing a camera's view onto that
texture in real time and if you notice
you can see our gun that's kind of hard
to see actually see they do it from from
there maybe
yeah there we I've seen a little bit
better there when we move we can see the
gun
so we it's we can see that it
surrendering at real time and that's the
power of a render texture and this will
allow you to do all kinds of things you
can have like you know TV screens in
your game that are rendering another
part of your scene
obviously an example like this or you
have a portal looking into another area
now if you apply a perspective
correction to this whereby your camera
actually tracks where your players
position is relative to the portal you
can accomplish a much more believable
look and you can actually make it seem
as if you're looking into another area
because the camera is literally moving
with your player so the cameras like the
stuff that it's capturing is gonna be
changing in real time not only just your
characters model right the actual angle
is gonna change and therefore be
perspective correct and there's a
awesome tutorial that I'm going to link
to in the slides that'll show you how to
go about doing that it's really awesome
and so this is what it ends up looking
like this is actually before I changed
one of the portals had a slightly offset
camera angle so you can see here this is
like a little bit higher than this one
is they even though this should be
exactly the same but it's fixed now so
so texture masking off any questions
about any of that process before we talk
about texture masking okay so texture
masking is basically the process so
here's a if we just take a plane and we
put a rendered texture onto it that's
what it looks like it just looks like
it's just a square and this could work
fine if you want sort of a square portal
look you don't have to do any extra work
but if you want a circle right you can't
really create like a circle shaped plane
object that doesn't really exist and
even even it did it wouldn't be
efficient especially if you want a very
smooth plane because everything is
triangles and polygons right so if
you're if you have a circle it's gonna
be a bunch of these sort of fanned out
polygons especially a very high-rez
circle like one of these that's a very
high-rez circle making a polygon that
looks like that is not it's not an
optimal way to go about solving that
problem right a much more optimal way to
go about solving that problem would be
to say to designate certain pixels of
the TEC some texture as being pixels
that we want to read and then certain
other pixels being not pixels that we
to read and and therefore produce a the
final image that gets put on to a
geometry right and so what we end up
doing is creating an image first so it's
this image which is kind of hard to see
but it's just a simple sort of can you
see I see from the again so it's just a
simple oval right it's the exact shape
that we want our portal to look like and
the pixels that are white are the pixels
that we're gonna render and the pixels
that are black are the pixels that we
don't want to render I'm gonna consider
those as by pure zero alpha effectively
and using a awesome shader that you can
get for free just easily on the Unity
webpage this is just a masking shader
and I'm not great at writing shaders but
what this does is turns lighting off
first of all what happens if we have
lighting applied to our portals it's
gonna look a little weird right you're
gonna get like shadows cast on your
portals and that doesn't make sense
right because we're effectively supposed
to be looking into another another place
another area so we have shadows that are
being cast onto our thing we're
effectively like almost seeing like a
glass door on our portal right we it
sort of breaks the illusion so lighting
should be off a lot of these things I'm
not a hundred percent on because I'm not
great at writing shaders but it's a very
simple easy shader that you can grab off
of the unity webpage and the I think I
clipped the URL here at the very bottom
but I grabbed it off of the unity
webpage and all it does is it adds on to
your material this second image here and
it gets blown up a little bit because
unity makes any texture that you apply
to basically any texture you put into
like an image selector will get squit
made into a square shape and our image
is not square shape but what this does
is when you pass in this image which is
called a coaling mask it will basically
combine the two images and then cancel
out any of the pixels that are black on
the
on this it will effectively add the
black and white to the Alpha of the of
the texture pixels right so you can
actually make some of these gray and
then it'll have the effect of sort of
making it half transparent but in this
case I only went with full transparent
and full hard 255 alpha so we get sort
of a crisp outline for our portals and
that's what the that's how you end up
putting together a a basic sort of oval
shape on something that is just a flat
mesh and you can do this with anything
anytime you need to sort of take away
detail that would make making a mesh
extremely difficult or doing really cool
effects it's often just a lot easier to
create a mask for it and then create use
the right shader that's meant to have
that mask and then just manipulate that
however you need to and again the link
here for the shader is here and then you
can use this for pretty much anything
you want and result of that is we go
from having a square portal to a
elliptical portal so pretty nice I
didn't have to use a plane but it
doesn't really make sense to use
anything else because using a I mean
using a cube it would it would create
depth and we don't want the portal to
have any depth really right it's just be
a flat surface and then when we go
through it it's just teleport us to the
other surface to make it look sort of
seamless I don't think there's any other
I don't think there's another choice of
geometry that makes sense for this use
case
no I probably wouldn't you'd the make a
cylinder flat and project it and have no
depth on it the you would be able to
still see the rings on it and also
texturing that is a little bit more
complicated because then it's gonna it's
gonna you'd have to UV map your both
your sort of mask and your regular
texture on to that because by default
it's gonna wrap it weird just because
this is just a plain so whatever you
text your map on to which is gonna be
completely flat but a cylinder it's
gonna wrap it around all sides and it's
gonna look a little bit it's gonna look
a little bit funky
I suppose in theory you could use a
cylinder for it but I think would be a
tremendous amount of work I don't think
it would be anywhere near as easy as
getting it to work with just a flat
plane or a mesh interesting idea though
I guess you could theoretically create a
cylinder that has if you wanted to like
a bridge between two worlds and have one
end be one portal and one end be another
portal and then be able to walk between
them that's a cool idea maybe you can
make that work but I think for this the
the plane is the right way to go any
more questions as to sort of how that
works all right
so we'll talk about teleporting now so
teleporting is pretty easy all we really
need to do right is just create a mesh
Collider on the portal mesh the orange
portal on the blue portal and then when
that mesh Collider if that mesh Collider
is a trigger right and it collide it
detects a collision with something else
it's going to we can just define
ontriggerenter and then with that we can
teleport the collider other to the other
portals location so every portal this is
the portal component it has a linked
portal right because we need to know
where to teleport the player to the
other portal so we need to get know have
a reference to its transform whether
it's active right because if we allow
ourselves to teleport to another portal
and another portal like back and forth
just without any restraints what do you
think is
to happen infinite loop we just get an
infinite sort of weird flickering effect
so you need to effectively have like a
toggle switch on both portals and say as
soon as I enter a portal I should not be
able to teleport back into it right and
as soon as I teleport to another portal
I should not be able to teleport into it
either but once you exit a portal you
should be able to teleport back into it
and so what that effectively does is we
enter a portal it gets flagged as not
tell affordable right we get teleported
to the other portal as soon as that
happens this portal can now be
teleported into this portal that we're
standing in is now flagged as not
teleport able and then we walk out of it
and we're allowed to teleport back into
that one and the other one so it's
effectively an on/off operation that you
have to balance appropriately the actual
portal game is a little more complicated
because they allow you to walk in
between portals this does not go into
that level of detail and it's a more
complicated problem to solve this
example just assumes that you walk into
a portal you can teleport out the other
end and there's no sort of in-between
state and actually if you're in between
two portals there's a replication of
geometry which valve will talk about in
their talk as well which I think it'll
be very interesting because if you look
into another portal while you're in the
middle of a portal right you want to be
able to see yourself you know in that
portal right half way in and out of that
portal so there's a lot of interesting
considerations for getting very
believable portal systems but ours is a
very simple illustration and so this
toggle function is all that I have to
toggle the functions on and off
capability and all it is is just portal
active is not portal active and that
just flips that flag super easy
ontriggerenter we effectively cache our
position X on the x and z axis so we
don't rotate it because when we rotate
our X and Z on the first person
controller by default it causes some
really weird buggy behavior based on the
way that the FPS controller works so all
I do is I just cache I cache those
positions and then make it rotation on
the y axis and that'll save us that
weird
sort of going topsy-turvy effect that
you'll get if you use the FPS controller
by default and you do perform rotations
on it you'll notice this so I haven't
had the time to dig in depth as to how
to fix it but this is the way that I was
able to fix it for this example at least
is only only allow yourself to rotate on
the y-direction which is where you're
looking in sort of like the ground
relative to the ground plane and that'll
allow us to rotate based on where we're
exiting the portal at least on the sort
of walls that are going up and down and
then have that sort of believable effect
it doesn't allow us to like jump down
into a portal from up above and see us
coming down from the other portal which
is a cool effect unfortunately but it
does allow us you know sort of to get
most of the way there and so we set our
position to the other portals position
and our rotation but only the Y we get
the Y and then we set it here using
Euler angles on our players transform
and then there's a function that I
called that I created called mouse reset
which effectively just calls init again
on the FPS controllers rotation on the
the camera and the player and then
that's sort of like the hack that you
need in order to so the reason that a
lot of the weirdness exists is because
the player controller caches its
rotation information and so if you
perform a rotation on a on your FPS
controller by hand as opposed to
allowing it to happen with the mouse it
will immediately reset it back to its
prior position in rotation which has the
effect of when we teleport from one
portal to another even though we set our
direction of rotation to be like outside
going in the direction of where the
portals facing we end up having the same
position the rotation that we did enter
in the portal so we end up coming out of
portals often just backwards and so
that's some that's just a limitation of
the first-person controller but you can
fix that by calling mouse reset which is
a function that essentially just calls
init again which is an it is part of the
FPS controllers Mouse look object I
won't go too much into detail about it
just cuz it's a little bit arcane and
the the source codes in there if you
want to take a look and dabble with it
but effectively preventing it from
cashing its rotation information and
just hard setting it and then recalling
the mouse look init function which does
the actual setting of the rotation on
the camera and the and the player a
little bit a little bit weird but that's
unities FPS controller and that's how
other people are saying to fix it so you
could roll your own you can create your
own FPS controller and probably prevent
this from happening but if you wanna use
the regular FPS controller that's sort
of the limitation there but it's mostly
working and it looks pretty good some
more time on end we could probably make
it look even better but for now I think
it's good so that's teleporting say your
position and then set your Y rotation
override the FPS controllers default
rotation caching and we can walk in this
portal and then instantly walk out this
portal that's what we see so any
questions as to how sort of this works
in a nutshell or any of the maybe any of
the code here in our portal alright so a
much better version of the portal at
least from the rendering side is this
video here so it's Brack ease so he's a
very good he explains things very well
he's got very high quality to his videos
he creates a bunch of unity tutorials
and in this case he created a portal
that used a sort of shader an
interesting shader that'll only render
everything but geometry and also onto a
plane in which case this plane and does
the camera interpolation of the player
that I alluded to before which allows us
to actually have so these are two
separate worlds in tandem right now so
there's this red world here and then
this camera is looking at a completely
different green world that's completely
like set off onto the in the distance
that's the exact same geometry but
completely colored green as opposed to
red and if you look through here it's
just completely seamless and the
walkthrough is completely seamless and
he goes in the detail
to how he accomplished all of this if
you're curious and he provides you the
shader that you can use for free so
definitely check that out if that's of
interest there's a link there in the
video and here's a link to his youtube
series if you want to I put some of
these in the slack because somebody
requested some AI videos and the he has
a bunch of different AI videos and a
bunch of other really cool series so you
can take a look at that if curious and
the best version sort of portal
obviously is the portal itself and Dave
cursor and TGIF Kohli are employees at
valve who worked on portal and they'll
be here on May 2nd to give a talk as to
all of the technical sort of things that
went behind the scenes and related to
rendering and physics and just getting a
believable and good and good feeling
experience with portal for the actual
polished final game that we're talking
about so definitely come to that talk if
you're curious we're gonna take a break
and then as soon as we come back we're
gonna talk a little bit about some new
tools the entity has released called pro
builder and pro grids and we'll talk
about the assignment and that'll be it
for G d50 all right welcome back this is
lecture 10 so we talked about portal
before the break we talked about ray
casting we talked about render textures
sort of what those are how easy it is to
make those in unity we talked about how
to give our first-person controller a
gun so that we could actually look
around and look as if we're holding a
weapon we talked about the portals
themselves how we're masking out the
texture the render texture as applied to
a plane and how each of those has a
camera behind it so that it can render
what is going out from the portal in the
direction that it's facing we're going
to deviate from portal now and talk
about pro builder and pro grids which
are two tools that are part of the new
unity 20 18.1 which will allow us to
actually model geometry per the
screenshot this is actually a level that
I created and that is in the distro it
allow us to create geometry in the
actual scene view without needing to go
into a third-party program like blender
or Maya and have to sort of alternate
between the two and import and export
you know incessantly not only that but
as soon as you model something like this
in unity in the scene view you can
immediately test it for game
play and make sure that it actually fits
what you want and you'll have to worry
about scale issues when you're importing
and sort of making it work and figuring
out ultimately that oh I don't like the
way this mesh this level is let me go
and tweak it and redo it it just allows
you a ton of ease and flexibility and I
made I previously mentioned Brad keys
before but he's got a couple of awesome
tutorials here on pro builder and pro
grids to supplement sort of what we'll
talk about today in lecture but if you
want sort of more of a showcase of all
the features of both then you can look
at these videos here and get a sense of
how they work
so we're gonna go ahead and just mess
around with pro builder a little bit
here in the scene view so that we can
see what it looks like I'm going to open
up my other scene so I have the portal
scene appear in the distro this is where
all the stuff that we've been looking at
exists just the portal game there's a
pro builder scene as well which I'm
going to not save that and so this pro
builder scene is the level geometry that
I created earlier now it looks pretty
horrendous because I didn't spend a
terrible amount of time on it and I'm
not a particularly talented visual
designer by any stretch let me go ahead
and make it a little bit larger so that
we can see it a little better but it
showcases some of the interesting
features so we see you know we have
obviously sort of polygonal square
shaped rectangular geometry we can see
that some faces are textured and some
aren't
so we can see this face here for example
is just white material the default
material we can see that all of these
sort of have this brick texture which I
got off a procedural generator so I've
website that allows you to choose a like
a template for your texture and then you
know specify colors and stuff like that
I did the same thing for this texture
this is another procedural texture which
is kind of like a blue marble e-type
texture the cool thing about it is at
least for texturing you can just choose
arbitrary faces that you want to texture
rather than have to texture the whole
thing like you would do if you were to
just give a mesh a default material
it'll apply it to the whole mesh in this
case it's just applying it to whatever
faces we select and pro builder another
interesting thing which I really like is
pro builder gives you a lot of tools for
creating
special kinds of geometry very quickly
and efficiently in this case this is a
staircase which all I had to do was with
Pro Builder select build staircase and
then you can choose a lot of different
parameters we'll take a look at how to
do that in a second I did the same thing
here as notice this this staircase has
kind of a spiral to it and then this
staircase is really tall but has no
spiral and then we have another
staircase here which is kind of shorter
and doesn't have a spiral and then it
ends up coming up here to this point and
then if this were the assignment maybe
this spot here would be where you put
your Collider that says oh this is the
finish you know this is the levels
conclusion you've been in the level so
the assignment is with pro builder so to
make a level you know it doesn't have to
be anything terribly fancy like I'm not
a great designer but it should have at
least one section where you're required
to jump so some sort of jump puzzle just
so that you can you know think about the
design of your level a little bit
and it should be you know meaningfully
large not like it doesn't have to be
gargantuan and then and it shouldn't be
small it shouldn't be like 10 meters or
you know not so maybe not 10 meters but
it shouldn't be like you know 10 5
meters large obviously that's very small
it should be something that you would
consider you know a somewhat sizable
level using something of this sizes is a
fair a fair metric so pro builder if
you've installed pro builder so by
default pro builder is not installed in
your project you have to go to the asset
store I don't know
it's Asus there's been a little bit slow
last couple of days let's see if it
works quickly it looks like it is so if
we go to the asset store open this
connecting again getting being slow ok
so if you search for assets and you look
just type pro builder it's a little
pop-up here and notice that it says
unity technologies anything basically
that says unity technologies will be a
free sort of supplement to unity that
you can easily just import from the
asset store now it's a little bit
cramped the window here but in because
I'm in a 720p monitor but you just have
to click download and then import in
order to import it into your project the
distro for portal for assignment 10
already has a pro builder and pro grids
installed programs would be the exact
same process just pro grids right here
and when you an import both of those
into your project you'll immediately
have the ability to go up to tools and
you'll see pro builder and pro grids
here and all you need to do is click on
the whoops Pro builder and then Pro
builder window and you can see here this
nice little widget filled window pops up
and you can also dock it here if you
want to actually that on accident but
unity makes it pretty nice so you can
dock your stuff wherever you want it to
and there's a few different things so
you can do new shape and a new poly
shape the new shape actually gives you
like shape templates so here I have
chosen just cube by default and it
allows you do stairs prisms cylinder so
I just do a stair for example and then
we immediately see this like stair mesh
here right I can generate the number of
steps that I want just by changing the
slider I can change the curvature if I
want so that it's a rotating staircase
and then I can also change how wide and
how tall the stairs are and also this
inner radius is like how deep the steps
are if that makes sense and then all of
these together once you finish you just
hit build stair and it's done now you
have a stair mesh they can just put
anywhere in your level and it's that
easy to make stairs before I get into
more of the sort of what makes Pro
builder work I'm gonna go ahead and
enable pro grids so Pro grids is a cool
feature it's a cool sorry add-on which
will actually lock everything in your
scene to a specific grid which you can
designate based on how fine or coarse
you want the grid to be and what that'll
allow us to do is when I move notice
that it's moving on the grid right it's
not moving in continuous can like sort
of a continuous motion it's actually
discrete steps and the advantage of
doing things this way is that when
you're modeling your level or whatnot
you know let's say you have a maybe a
can or a sort of a diagram or a drawing
they've created you slap it on a texture
they know a flat mesh in your scene and
then you just sort of draw your level on
top of it everything will sort of just
like map up nice and cleanly when you're
creating all your your geometry and you
can snap things together and they'll
align all in the same axes and it makes
creating levels like this just a lot
easier you don't have to worry about
things being slightly off and then like
missing vertices and
sort of be looking a little bit unclean
this ensures that everything is very
clean so again just notice the discrete
steps that it's moving these are all
locked to the grid here and so you can
change all the settings here as to like
how large it is if I create a cube so
I'm going to go ahead and create a new
cube and it build it notice up here
these four buttons are sort of like the
modes with which we can interact with
our cube and this is very similar to
what you get in 3d software like blender
or Maya or whatnot you choose vertices
with the left Mouse and then you can hit
shift to select multiple and then you
can just move it and since I'm using pro
grids snapping it to the to the grid
right so if I turn off Pro grids it
should just be continuous like that and
so you can get whatever sort of angles
you want depending on what your your use
case is so I'm gonna go ahead and hit
command Z if I click on the face mode
and I click this face and i shift-click
it'll actually extrude it and make a new
face and I can keep doing this over and
over again I'm going to zoom out a
little bit so I can see a little bit
better and I extrude that and then I
extrude that right starting to build
something right it's not beautiful but
it's something I can extrude that again
right I believe I can scale as well so
you can build it out like that can and I
haven't spent a ton of time mastering
how to use the tool and all the ins and
outs of it but it is very I think useful
if you're looking to get into sort of
level design and you want to avoid the
overhead of you know dealing with
third-party software like blender or
Maya and having model files that you're
sort of importing and exporting it can
be kind of a pain however if you want to
export models you can definitely do that
so there is a method here forget which
one it is off
and think it's this one no it's one of
these allows you to save the model I
don't remember exactly which one it is
is it this one and then use a little bit
cramped here so I'm gonna actually blow
it up yeah yeah offhand I can't recall
which of these allows you to actually
export out have the icons memorized yet
because it's a fairly new tool but one
of these will allow you to actually
export the object as FBX or obj whatever
your software is that you end up wanting
to so you can just go also go up to here
to the export menu which is a lot easier
to see everything by name and you can
choose how you want it to export you can
also export assets to for your for your
game so you can have objects in your
scene that Pro Builder will generate for
you so you create prefabs that way but
then here's like obj so that you can
export it to your 3d renderer 3d
software of choice this is relevant for
situations where for example you want to
like rig and model and animate a mesh
you can't do any sort of rigging in pro
builder but you can do that in through
other 3d software so it makes sense to
export it that way you can also create
the model here export it rig it and then
re-import it if you want to and that's
relevant this is a useable scene as this
right now the lighting gets a little bit
messed up notice here when you mess with
stuff but that gets fixed there's a
little sort of meter here where it does
some calculating and by default will
actually bake lighting on all of your
objects but as is this will perfectly
collide with it with with any characters
that you have so I have a FPS character
and I bring this guy up let's go ahead
and set the transform here just put them
in the right position and programs is
like attaching that like sort of making
that grid visible next to where I am and
you can set the access for that
currently I have it actually disabled so
if I enable it now this will actually
move in increments see and it will snap
it to the grid perfectly but
now this as soon as I hit play I'm
actually going to close this
I should just be on this mesh up here
yep and so this is just part of the
scene now like as if you had made it in
blender or Maya or whatever if she
jumped down to my actual level and then
explore it a little bit this is all just
haphazardly created you know whoops
stairs and other meshes and stuff and so
you know make it all the way to the top
oh I fell down I'm also horrible at
playing games but this is the you know
the beauty of it is you can just play it
instantly right right out the gate now
another cool thing that I'd like to
showcase is what we talked about grey
boxing earlier from making interior
levels grey boxing is the purpose of
making levels and testing them for
playability the cool thing about pro
builder is that it has a in invert
normals feature which i think is just
general in like generally accessible in
3d software
I don't know offhand which menu it's in
actions geometry to have the right
things selected I'm going to open up the
pro tool pro builder window and then one
of these is invert invert selection up
sorry wait flip normals there we go and
so what this does is now this is an
interior level so all we did before was
you we made a sort of like polygonal
creation of arbitrary you know size and
shape if you invert the normals so
recall every like 3d polygons 3d surface
as a normal and whatever direction
that's facing going the opposite way
going towards that normal is what gets
rendered but the behind it if you're
going in the opposite direction of the
surface normal its invisible and so the
effect of that is if we flip all the
normals of something that is convex we
get an interior scene and we're looking
at it from the outside it looks a little
bit weird right like we
see into it right and this is something
that you might see like in Minecraft for
example when you're looking in part of
the geometry that you shouldn't be able
to see you can you can clip through the
world and see all the other like
interior parts of the world because
you've basically gone beyond the surface
normal of that polygon and you're only
seeing the the from that perspective all
the the surface normals of polygons that
are facing in your direction in that way
but often you'll allow you to look
straight through all of the other sort
of cubes that are along the way because
you're looking at all the rear of there
either the inverse of their surface
normal you're looking in that direction
and so again only one direction can a
polygon be lit at once and even if we
look at it from the top you can see that
as well
we're looking at it from the top flip
the normals it becomes a sort of concave
or convex 3d object flip them now it's
an interior level right so I'm actually
going to go into this and I'm gonna flip
the normals again I'm going to click on
this oh I would have to click on a lot
of these actually because it split up
the mesh but it's gonna be easy enough
I'm clicking all the top services of
this making sure I didn't get any on the
other side on accident I did not I'm
going to extrude this and then I'm going
to flip all the normals and then I'm
going to take my FPS controller which is
here and actually I think it's already
inside which it is I'm gonna hit play
the lighting I'm not sure if it'll be
messed up it is messed up because in the
middle of calculating a bunch of stuff
but now I've created an interior level
right with the weird mesh that I had
before and so if you make your if you
sort of make the building of your level
sort of you know this concave thing and
then you flip all the normals you can
create an interior scene very easily so
the ceiling and everything else
normally otherwise it would be kind of a
pain in the butt but makes it super easy
to do with pro builder and there's a lot
of other features a material editor for
one so with the material editor you can
actually designate specific materials so
in this case I've created a couple of
materials a brick texture here and a
marble texture which
I took some textures grading material
made the albedo component of those
materials that texture and what that
allows me to do is I can select an
arbitrary face so in this case I'm gonna
choose these faces and I can just click
on this brick texture and now these are
textured as that brick right it's not
applying it to the entire mesh it's just
applying it to whatever specific face
that we want to and there's a UV editor
which will allow you to actually take
the mesh of your model in this case this
is this is our entire mesh here just
remember as we talked about it last week
everything gets cut out and made flat so
you can sort of see if you remember the
shape of what we're dealing with all the
polygons that we were that comprised our
sort of weird large object they're all
now splayed out for us so we can just
very easily take a texture and just like
put it wherever we want on here now I
don't have a ton of experience using
this so I'm not 100% confident my
ability to uv-map something right now in
front of you but the documentation on
the pro builder website goes into detail
as to how to use this so if you wanted
say a specific texture to be like in
part of the mesh and then maybe another
texture to be another part of it and
it's in a specific like welded way
that's not like just splat onto it the
UV editor will help you with that for
example a face on a character model or
something else but yeah or maybe like a
sign on a door somewhere or something
like that you can do that all here just
click and drag all the faces the faces
are actually interdependent like
dependant from one another so that you
can lay them out in a way that fits the
texture that you are trying to map
everything to that is pro builder in a
nutshell there's a lot of features we
don't have time to cover all of them and
I mean frankly I just don't know all of
them super well yet just because the
technology is so new but it's I think
this is gonna be a huge part of like
unities future and like making it
accessible for people that would
otherwise have maybe been turned off by
the idea of modeling their level
geometry or their object geometry I mean
certainly for me now this this just
makes me want to make a game and unity
like right now just cuz like I know I
can instantly just like start creating
my levels right like it's just nice and
easy and convenient and pro grids you
should use definitely use programs in
tandem with pro builders so that you can
optimally rearrange things in a way such
that they're all like evenly lined up
with each other otherwise you're gonna
end up with issues in like manipulating
their position in a very specific way
and like coming up here and setting
their values manually and that's just
kind of a pain so much easier just to
snap everything to the grid the programs
and deal with it that way
and so the assignment is yeah largely
just going to be take the take pro
builder and pro grids and just like make
a level with it and then just like take
the principles that we've learned create
a controller create a collider and just
make a very simple scene and otherwise
probably spend your time focused on your
final project so any questions as to pro
builder how it works how to get it set
up
ya know it'll actually it'll it should
flip through it let me go ahead and put
this up here it actually actually it
might not I think it does still trigger
collision but you'll still you'll just
be able to walk you'll just be able to
see through the through the yeah it's
just a visual it's just a visual bug
it's a lighting bug the physics should
still apply I'm gonna go ahead and set
the model up here okay hit play
no actually look like it went through it
so I think it so it also inverts the
collision the collision box yeah I've
seen some games where you can clip
through something and still collide with
it so I think it depends on ultimately
the engine or the implementation that
you're using but in this case when you
flip the surface normals here of this
mesh it also flips the box Collider the
mesh colliders normals yeah precisely
yeah if you wanted you could have a you
could make a copy of the interior make
it you'd have to make it you make it the
same size I suppose and then flip its
and not flip its normals such that you
have a shell and an interior yeah
absolutely
yeah generally I don't think you mean to
the add to pants if a lot of interior
levels you will never ever be outside of
their boundaries and so you don't often
see that happening but it's very much
the case that you could have that
happening and if you have like a house
model for example then yeah you'll often
you actually see house models are
modeled with walls that are two planes
so there's a bit of thickness it's
actually a rectangular shape so it
allows you to have a collision on one
side and another side because both
there's two planes of the collider
rather than just a single plane which is
the direction of the surface normal any
further questions on probability yeah
because the bottom surface normal is
pointed upwards so this this right here
is pointed upwards but notice that here
the surface normals actually pointed
down so you can only collide with the
direction of the surface normal that's
facing you if that makes sense
you can walk you can walk through you
can walk towards the direction of the
surface normal but not like against the
surface normal if that makes sense
that's the way that unity calculates its
mesh renderer component
you could go through from this direction
but you could not go through this
direction because this direction the
surface normal is pointed this way right
so if we try to walk against it will be
walking against the normal and so we
won't be able to
we won't will we will trigger a
collision but if you're walking through
it and such that you're going the same
direction as the surface normal so if
you're coming from this direction then
it won't detect a collision that make
sense yeah
what tani suggested which was to make a
shell around it would solve that problem
so if we created this this exact mesh
duplicated it and then inverted it then
we would have two of the same object but
with normals going one direction and
almost going the other direction such
that the mesh renderers account for both
potential movement directions cool all
right any further questions on pro
builder again not to meant to be a
comprehensive tutorial there's videos
and documentation that I have linked to
in the slides but more just to
illustrate how awesome this tool is
really and that this is probably gonna
save some people doing unity project
sometime if you're doing any unity like
if you're doing any asset modeling I
should say our level modeling another
thing that we didn't I didn't make a
slide for but which I talked about in
class was shader graph and so what
shader graph is is another twenty
eighteen point one feature which allows
rather than having to write shaders in
shader lab which is unities shader
language
which can be quite quite an experience
quite intimidating you can actually
create them now with this node based
programming language not really
programming language but there's no base
programming environment I should say
which will allow you to choose all these
preset nodes that influence the shaders
behavior and there's a lot of different
kinds and have the result of that be you
can see your shader every step of the
way
so the shader is just a series of
transformation
is going from left to right in one
direction all of these sort of
transformations you can see how they end
up accumulating to produce this final
effect in which case here if it may be
kind of part of this hard to discern is
a sort of marine guy with these blue
holes that are actually like masking his
mesh and we talked about masking earlier
this shader itself looks like it's
applying a mask with this noise that is
generating and it comes with noise
generation functions generation nodes
which will allow you to feed those into
sort of like the mass component of your
shader and then produce some very
interesting cool effects otherwise this
would be kind of unless you're like a
shader expert which I am NOT it would be
pretty complicated and non-trivial to
implement something like this with just
code but this generates code for you
such that you don't have to actually
write any code at all but you can still
see the produced shader that gets
created for you from shader lab or
shader graph
I'm believe that it's just a asset now
I'm not a hundred percent sure I didn't
test this going in hopefully I'm not
just missing it supposedly you should be
able to just import it I'm not a hundred
percent let's see how you actually is
that this article maybe uses it via the
package manager package manager I think
this is a new window package manager so
we go to window and then package manager
and and all
and then shadowgraph yep so right here
so window and then package manager and
then shader graph and that will allow
you to import the means to which by
which to create these sort of graph
layouts if you're using twenty eighteen
point one which the course is using but
if you're at home and you're using
twenty seventeen point four then update
to twenty eighteen point one and you
should see this in your package manager
and then once you do that you can create
a you can actually create a new shader
graph object and then you'll see it as a
new window that pops up in your scene
and then you can start adding nodes I
don't have any material prepared for it
and I did anticipate talking about it
necessarily but it's something that
seems to be very game-changing and it's
something unreal has had for a long time
but sort of differentiated it from unity
in my opinion and it's I think a very
about valuable thing that they've added
that shows a lot of awesome progress for
2018 so again a link to bra keys if you
want details on how to use not only pro
builders and pro pro builder and pro
grids but a lot of other awesome
features of unity and to do a lot of
cool stuff he makes some really cool
videos assignment ten so assignment ten
is going to be creating a level with pro
builder just to get your hands wet with
it
the level should be pretty complex so
not like I said earlier not like a
finished game level like I'm not
expecting you to do awesome amazing
incredible things but a level that has
maybe you know a few pieces of
interesting geometry maybe generate some
stairs generate some it has some pipes
you can generate and some other things
have a jumping puzzle in there so this
this says there should be one jumping
puzzle for the player the assignment
doesn't officially say it yet but I'm
gonna make the change to make it say
that there should be a jumping puzzle
you can interpret this however you want
just a couple platforms is fine but
honestly whatever whatever you would
like and have two different textures or
materials so you can create just an easy
piste import whatever textures you want
or you can go to a website that allows
you to procedurally create a texture
and you can assign it to a material put
it in the material editor of pro builder
and then use that to assign it to a face
or to the whole object if you want to
but it should be at least to not the
default so to make it a little
interesting use many more if you want to
but only two you're required so there
this should be kind of like a complete
scene so make a new scene separate from
the pro builder scene separate from the
portal scene include an FPS controller
so that we can move around the scene
immediately after creating the mesh
right but that's it you can just use the
default controller you don't need to do
anything fancy and then at the very end
you should have a trigger on a Collider
somewhere which should probably can be
invisible it doesn't have to be
invisible you can make this whatever you
want you can make like an arch or I
don't know your imagination is you're
free to use your imagination as much as
you want but there needs to be some
Collider whether it's invisible or not
at the very end and a trigger it needs
to be a trigger and then when you
collide with it it should say level
complete on the screen so just take a
text object from unity 2d part of the
canvas and just drag if you just add a
UI text in the scene it'll automatically
add a canvas and an event system for you
create the label and then just set it to
on or off depending on whether or not
you've collided with the trigger there's
code for this in the helicopter game in
the game over text script you can see
exactly how this is done all it
effectively is is setting the color of
the text to zero zero zero zero versus
row zero zero one or whatever color you
want to effectively just to change on
the Alpha component of the text color
and then once that's done then you have
a complete assignment and then you can
spend more energy hopefully this should
only take maybe an hour maybe less you
can spend more energy on your final
project which would be due on the 11th
but altogether it's been an awesome
pleasure teaching this course and I hope
that a lot of you were able to learn a
lot of interesting things and hopefully
we're inspired to create some of your
own projects and we'll continue to
create some of your own products in the
future I certainly enjoyed making a lot
of the stuff and especially Super Mario
Brothers I think that was my favorite
but this was G d50 so thank you so much
you